did you see what Scott Adams tweeted I
yeah I think I what yes what is that I
know it's not mom he said what what did
he say do you remember exactly what he
said I didn't see it yes I did we saw it
he said I didn't see it we are all
laughing about it no wait I don't think
I did okay no he said there's very good
possibility that if Biden is elected
you'll be dead within the year yeah
Republicans will be hunted yeah and I'm
just like that's it was it meant to be
over the top on purpose
probably I saw some people saying that
with just like three tweets he got them
all triggered and going nuts and ate and
that the point may have been to do that
but now it's like it's just it makes him
and it makes Trump supporters look
insane completely insane I don't know I
don't know the goal was to like make
Trump supporters look bad well
stereotypes in general I don't like so
it's like sure he he personally put that
out there he doesn't represent me he
does not perceive let's talk about
persuasion sure that is popping up on a
whole bunch of sub brides having nothing
with nothing to do with politics
like insane people Facebook okay and
regular people are just like face
palming and shaking their heads like
whoa Trump supporters are crazy I think
I think there's people on both sides are
that are crazy that are just they are
separated from the average person that's
looking at both sides going I don't
understand either either group here so I
don't understand if you want to convince
regular people to vote for Trump the
last thing you want to say is that
they're coming to kill me help help okay
well I don't I don't go to Scott for my
political advice I'm not saying you do
I'm asking why would you say something
like what's the point of doing that why
would he say it because he his job is to
sell cartoons and to have that like be
in the public eye so you think he was
just trying to like generate buzz for
himself that's what the news does for I
don't have we not figured that out with
mainstream news guy doesn't he's okay he
may not be news but he's he's on a
platform that he needs his comics to be
read he needs his his name to be spread
and it worked so sure okay he's not a
news man but he's a he's he's in the
light of of the Internet hurting Trump
supporters
make money sure isn't that that yeah
that seems to have worked over the past
four years it's very simple I mean know
a lot of the stuff he was doing was like
explaining Trump's tax I'm not
specifically talking about him I'm
saying in general people orange man bad
orange man bad and he but he's not an
orange mad bad personality that's the
issue okay so yeah he's his own his own
creation sure yeah so what it just makes
I mean hey whatever whatever his goal is
it makes Republicans look like like like
they're lunatics yeah like paranoid
delusional oh no they're coming to kill
me what do I do and then you get the CNN
people acting like anti fraud doesn't
exist yeah and it when it's convenient
I'm sick of this this idea that most
people are just ignorant fools that will
just fall for everything I don't believe
it I just do not believe it for everyone
I meet sure there's those ignorant
people that are just like okay I believe
whatever you say yes but you know for
the most part a lot of people think for
themselves they want to learn they they
don't just read a headline ago yeah
those people exist but for the most part
people are like okay that's a little
far-fetched I'm gonna need a little bit
more I'm gonna need a little bit more
it's like okay sure
reddit or Twitter but we know Twitter's
2% of the population how much it's
probably less on reddit active active
Twitter daily active Twitter users 2% of
the population okay daily active general
active whether like tweet once a month
is 22 okay
that's following that's still a small
margin of the general public yeah so
it's we're like hey it's the political
sphere though yeah but I'm not gonna
fall into this thing that I'm like yeah
all right well that clearly it's
everyone it's like all Trump supporters
must be like this because there's
nothing to do with what I'm talking
about the small group on reddit that are
saying look at look at this guy and I
didn't say small group I said it's
opening up in a whole sort of mainstream
spaces where people are like whoa chomp
supporters have gone insane so the main
their bases are are what done various
like it's all over Facebook right it's
all it's on it's on Facebook reddit
and Twitter and go and people are taking
old Dilbert comics and they're rewriting
the text so that it sounds so Dilbert
says they're gonna kill you and it's
funny in my opinion okay so when I see
like regular people easily getting
propaganda to make Trump look bad I have
to wonder
what was the point of saying it to get
people triggered that's the whole trolls
on the internet that's literally what
they go on the internet to do yes
they're trolling so Scott Adams is
trolling sure yeah that's all I'm asking
like what was what what was his
intention I don't know it's a crazy
tweet yeah to have people share it and
they did it went viral very viral boom
he nailed it that's exactly what he was
trying yes I guess the Trump supporters
are gonna rush to him now they're gonna
be like this guy gets it this guy this
guy knows what's up and then the left is
gonna be like while he's per law insane
but he's not trying to cater to that
audience so he's building an audience
off of well I think it's I think it's
ridiculous but that's not gonna change
how I feel about the man about Trump
mm-hmm no I'm talking about Scott Adams
okay but but it also creates when you've
got regular people in the middle and
you're trying to persuade them yeah to
either agree with you or not yeah you
think those regular people in the middle
are on Twitter following him or seeing
these things no but they're on Facebook
and their grant they're there they're 17
year old you know Gen Z's is sharing
with them and they're like whoa
basically this is a freaking it's the
Wild West it's either you're down one
side or the other there is no middle
ground so as far as like regular people
they're probably like sick of seeing
both of the sides it's like a wharf like
it's like walking through a wharf field
and bullets are whipping by you that's
what Facebook feels like there are a lot
of people that talk about how they were
D radicalized through various social
media platforms they were either on the
left or on the right and they switch
sides and so there's a constant
ideological battle to prove who's right
and who's wrong okay so if you if you're
creating what I would I would argue that
what Scott Adams just did was left-wing
black propaganda okay if you were trying
to figure out what the goal of that was
and who would benefit it's so that you
know Joe Biden would benefit greatly
from that tweet okay those tweets
because a regular person who wakes up
from 20 has a coma in 2019 wakes up
today and then sees someone tweeting
about how you're gonna be dead in a year
they're gonna be like oh these people
have gone insane as it's crazy no one's
gonna be dead like I'm a big fan of not
stereotyping anybody because I've been
stereotype for so long it's like yeah I
was a model on everyone knew who I was
and then I traveled and lived in Europe
for a while and everyone knew who I was
because I was an American and it's like
I'm sick of it nobody knows who anyone
is until you actually get to know them
that's all races anyone it's just like
it's a ridiculous thing that everyone
loves to clump anyone and everyone
together to be like I know exactly who
you are it's like no no no one knows who
anyone is until you actually get to know
them personally their character their
their heart that's what you need to know
and it's like and I think that that is a
lot more widespread than what it what
we're seeing on the Internet
you know it Scott Adams like sure he
made that like you said it's funny it's
funny to you so you see that it's funny
so what do you think the percentage of
of the people that actually saw that
that just think it's funny probably a
fairly large amount funny in the sense
of like what do you mean I don't know
you were the one who told me it was
funny what do you mean then yeah so I
think it's funny because it's like one
of the most absurd things I've ever seen
right okay so going on that and he
doesn't come off as intentionally trying
to be funny he comes off as serious so
my take away the humor in it if I'm
trying to dissect what he was saying and
what his goal was he was trying to make
Trump supporters look like morons okay
that's what if that's what it felt like
I don't think it's a case so then the
alternative is that there you know he is
just losing his mind yeah yeah like I
can talk about civil conflict and I
always preface this with two years ago
almost three years ago mm-hmm uh it was
like New York mag wrote about the
possibility of a civil war coming at a
high probability and that's when I first
brought it up then you have this one
professor peter Turchin who said
violence in 2020 upcoming civil war I
talk about it again and you have Brett
Weinstein say we're entering this
possibility then you have Bill Maher so
I'm I'm taking my cues from high-profile
people not just the comedian's but
professors and experts yeah but to come
out and say that you'll be dead within a
year so you're just saying that Scott
was completely irresponsible in that I
don't know look that's what I'm hearing
from you I'm wondering if it seems like
that's exactly what you're saying
it's I'm wondering if he was literally
sitting there thinking in a year if
Biden wins that tons of people will be
dead because they'll be hunting
Republicans down do you I do not think
that will happen no no no no do you
think that that does he really think
that do you think that that's what he
thinks I lean towards yeah okay I lean
towards he was serious now is that now
is that because you you think personally
that there's there's a chance that that
is possible or do you think that that's
he's thinking because he thinks that
it's possible or maybe a little bit of
both I think he tweeted it and he thinks
it's possibility he got because I
because you know I've made the mistake
of I think I don't know it's called
Poe's law or something
we must mark everything as satire I made
a joke about Aunt Jemima everyone
thought it was real and I'm like are you
kidding me like I people are nuts yeah
right so so perhaps it was meant to be a
big joke but I I have no idea
well the inflections the the nuance in
the the way you say things doesn't is
lost yeah on the Internet and that's a
big huge issue everyone takes it so
literal because they take it through
their perspective they read it how they
are feeling how they're at what their
moment is or they weaponize it's
purposefully to the worst possible the
same thing same thing it's their
perspective they're like I'm gonna that
that's how I'm looking at it right now
so that's the way it is so fu if that's
the the person who wrote that even
though that they were totally joking and
it was like light-hearted but doesn't
matter because text doesn't carry yeah
well neither do I this is a weird tweet
but that was fun that was a good rant
yeah I love I love thanks for checking
out this clip from the Tim cast IRL
podcast we do the show live Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. if you want to
catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe hit the like button or
check us out on iTunes and Spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you